le personnel hospitalier attendons des
réponses concrètes de la part du
gouvernement
malgré les annonces du premier ministre
de l'administration de la santé ce
week-end et la volonté du gouvernement
d'instaurer un ségur de la santé les
syndicats des milieux hospitaliers
maintiennent la menace d'une
mobilisation le 16 juin à créteil
aujourd'hui des dizaines de soignants
ont manifesté leur mécontentement
écouter on a vécu des moments hyper
difficile pendant la période qu'ovide là
ça va un peu mieux mais on a on a manqué
de matériel
nous avons envoyé des renforts des gens
qui étaient peu formés
et donc donc ça a été très très
difficile pendant un moment et là
aujourd'hui
montre qu'on est mécontent de ce qui
s'est passé et que si on avait eu plus
de lits
dorée a sans doute mieux passer comme en
allemagne
voilà c'est l'heure du conte et c'est
l'heure de relancer leurs revendications
qu'il y aura peut-être des prochainement
d
les mobilisations nous nos
revendications n'ont pas changé c'est
une augmentation salariale que nous
problème l'alma chrome on attend de voir
concerner tout le monde
c'est à dire tous les professionnels pas
que les soignants hôpital également des
administratifs et des services
techniques qui sont très souvent oublié
on veut également des embauches on
travaille en sous effectif depuis trop
d'années et on veut des budgets
hospitaliers à la hauteur des besoins de
la population parce qu'on supprime
depuis des années des milliers de vie et
qu'on n'arrive plus aubry à répondre aux
besoins de la population
on a les personnels qui sont épuisés
physiquement épuisés psychologie font
des heures sup initialement devait être
payé presque gracieusement et grassement
finalement il ya du retard on sait même
pas si on va les avoir les primes que
tout le monde devait toucher pareil
c'est le fiasco
enfin voilà on va sur des provinces que
personne ne tient pas ce gouvernement ne
tient pas et tant l'impression qu'ils
donnent à chaque jour qui évolue ont
l'impression qu'ils mettent la france
porte sur une jambe de bois pas